a nearly two-hour long phone call
between u.s president joe biden and xi
jinping has ended the leaders of the
world's two biggest economies spoke for
the first time since november washington
wants to stop beijing from providing
military and economic help to vladimir
putin chinese state media reports she
has told biden that conflict is not in
anyone's interest for more on this let's
head to
the white house where our correspondent
kimberly hellcat is standing by
kimberly first time these two leaders
have spoken since the war in ukraine
began what are the two men trying to
achieve and are there any hints of any
progress
well what we know is from the u.s side
the white house press secretary was very
clear about what the united states and
the west was hoping to achieve and that
was to really pin down from a u.s
standpoint from the western standpoint
where exactly china stands with regard
to its relationship with russia in other
words there has been grave concern about
the in the words of the white house
press secretary jinsaki the absence of
denunciation by china with regard to the
russian invasion of ukraine and
according to her she believes that
speaks volumes around the world and as a
result there's also been a lot of
concern about the alignment between
china and russia
specifically reports that china has
potentially been selling weapons to
russia to assist
in the ground fighting as well as in the
air and so this has been something that
the u.s president was hoping to try and
secure in terms of
where this relationship is moving
forward where the united states can
count on china and whether or not the
united states and the west can count on
china to use its economic leverage with
russia to potentially secure a ceasefire
in this conflict so this is the sort of
essence of the call we know that it
lasted nearly two hours the u.s
president took it in the situation room
of the white house that is a secure
location
and that this comes on the heels of a
discussion that took place earlier in
the week between the national security
adviser jake sullivan and his
counterpart in rome that conversation
lasting about seven hours so you can see
there was a lot to discuss and again a
lot of concern about where china stands
and whether or not it will assist in
trying to resolve this crisis
and kimberly as you mentioned sort of
it's no secret that this relationship
has been strained at the best of times
talk us through the relationship between
she and uh bro and biden
well the u.s president has said that he
believes that
chinese president xi is his friend but
when it comes to
their
sort of ideological perspectives they're
very different
the us president spoke about this in
fact as he was speaking at a luncheon on
capitol hill just on thursday he said
that chinese president xi
believes that there is no future for
democracy and the u.s president believes
just the opposite he believes that this
is an inflection point in history in
other words that the battle right now
globally is between autocracies
and democracies the u.s president
believing democracies will prevail and
that is not a view shared by chinese
president xi and so this is where the
battle of ideologies comes in and it
really transcends everything whether
it's the military whether it's the
economy uh whether it is the social
structure of these two nations and this
is why their differences have been at
times so difficult to resolve and we've
seen this play out for years
not just when it comes to the economic
relationship the sanctions that have
been levied against one another and
their economies but also over the issue
of taiwan and the concerns that the
united states has there and some of the
actions that the that china has taken uh
militarily and and sort of asserted
itself in the south china sea so uh
these are things that the united states
and the west are watching very closely
they're watching closely as china exerts
its pressure on russia because of course
this could have another chapter in in
its own region that would make the
united states very nervous so this is
why the united states is trying to keep
this dialogue open the press secretary
believes that there is the opportunity
to resolve some of these different
differences and at the same time have a
potential ceasefire in this imminent
crisis oh to be a fly on the wall during
that conversation kimberly thank you
very much for breaking it down for us
kimberly hellcat live for us in
washington dc